[Music]
even I'm not even us to
this oh my goodness you guys I just had
the most epic experience here at the
Porsche experience Center Los Angeles I
just I'm oh my gosh I'm speechless I got
a chance to drive the Porsche 911
Carrero 4S around their track do all of
these incredible experiences I'm still
feeling so mind blown from what I just
did the whole reason that we're actually
here is because it's Porsche's 75th
anniversary and they partnered with Xbox
to make six custom Xboxes uh out of
these six let's guess which one I picked
you're right this one right here it was
called The Pink Pig more on that later
but first let's get back on the track
and then we'll do the
[Music]
unboxing so let's walk through this
entire experience the first thing thing
is you are greeted with your vehicle now
you do choose your car ahead of time
when you make your reservation but when
you actually get here you're paired with
a coach who will take you from Zero to
Hero and there's no prior Professional
Driving Experience necessary because um
not going to lie I don't have any first
they get you warmed up and familiar with
your car and you start out slow going
around some of the tracks and the
obstacles just kind of getting your
bearings you know just drive around get
a feel for it okay just get used to the
handling circuit from the driver's side
[Music]
but then before long once they were
confident enough that I could do the
launch mode we went 0 to 60 to actually
I think my top speed was 117 on the
straightaway and it was so much fun and
we continued to do that several more
times until we had to move on and I'm
sure in the comments some of you are
going to be like but I've gone faster in
my good for you good for you I have not
this is let me have my moment thank you
Full Throttle are you are you ready am I
ready I don't know okay I don't Know
full power three 3 2 1 go off the break
there it is relax deep breath Full
Throttle keep it going keep it
going all the way to that billboard you
got it keep going 3 2 1 Breaking oh man
nice yep we cycled through several other
obstacle courses the one that I actually
enjoyed the most was going from launch
mode to slamming on the brakes as fast
as we could I think that was one of the
things that I was actually most
impressed with was how quickly this has
the ability to well stop you which in a
scenario like this yep that's pretty
important we then entered the low
friction Circle which was probably where
I struggled the most trying not to
completely spin out on this waterfill
circle that we kept rotating
around it's engaging see how much more
we're sliding now oh so should I
hit the brake or what like what's the uh
we're going to learn how to counter
steer we're going to counteract the
slide with our steering wheel off
throttle turning right turning right oh
oh you see we're going to just to turn
quite a bit so should I turn faster yes
we'll turn a little bit faster and feel
free to turn as much as it
needed it took me a few tries but I did
finally manage to get the hang of it
okay so it wasn't that time or that time
H the clip's here somewhere I I think
anyway we moved on to something even
more challenging which they were calling
the kick plate so basically this is just
kind of kicking out your back wheels and
it causes you to spin out very very
quickly so if you're able to recover and
handle it then A+ for you I failed the
first few times but did manage to get
the last two do I want to do it fast
that okay that is the name of the game
here it's all Reaction Time eyes on the
target coting drift Coast Coast
Coast yes St up yes
awesome that wasw so yeah okay all right
felt good right so good that was awesome
now using all of the skills that I've
just learned we then took a spin all the
way around on the course several times
each time getting a little bit faster I
think the coolest part about this is
there was never a point where I ever
felt uncomfortable the coaches are there
to guide you to tell you when to break
to accelerate and to really let you push
these cars to the Limit that you're
comfortable with and with every passing
lap I was getting more comfy more cozy
on this course and with this car you
want to do a few more laps whatever
whatever okay we'll do a couple
more
I did a few more laps and just when I
thought it was over the electric Porsche
tyon pulled up and my incredible coach
that I had all day took me for a proper
spin around the course all the turns are
so familiar that's right it's like a
roller coaster you've already been on
but they made it a little
quicker we surviv you you survived me
driving and you did amazing so it was
easy coaching it was so so easy that was
unbelievable I'm
disheveled but thank you so much awesome
it was so much fun I gathered up my
items and the Porsche pink pig Xbox and
it's time for lunch or so I thought we
took a slight detour first like at the
end of any amusement park ride there's a
gift shop all of the pink pig items of
course caught my eye so we got a
backpack and a duffel and a mug and a
t-shirt although the T-shirt was
actually a kid size but thankfully it
fit well enough than thank you we were
all pink pigged out we just did the
entire experience it was so much fun but
there's also a little bonus surprise we
actually get to have lunch here I've got
my new Pink Pig shirt on and I'm going
to unbox the Xbox upstairs while we have
lunch let's go I've been to a lot of
restaurants in Los Angeles and I'm not
going to lie this restaurant was
actually really good it was kind of
unexpected because I was here to drive
cars not have a delicious meal but what
a treat I got both and an Xbox unboxing
on top top of it the Highlight though
let's just take a moment to pause for
the Porsche shaped butter it's so cute
and they even let me take a few Frozen
ones home they're currently right now
sitting in my freezer the appetizers
were amazing the main course was amazing
everyone had such a delicious meal and
there was even dessert the dessert has
arrived look at this this is like a
spectacular
view so good truly I think I could
probably make an entire full video on
just my meal alone but let's move on to
the main course the star of the show The
Pink Pig Xbox and one of the reasons why
I got a chance to do this experience in
the first place I got a little tag okay
here's the controller oh look at
that and now for the
Xbox there she is this is so beautiful
look at this so the history of this pink
pig Livery is actually pretty
interesting this car was originally a
one-off experimental vehicle that
competed in the 1971 lemons now it was
designed to create a more aerodynamic
version of the 9917 but with its more
rounded shape it kind of looked like a
pig so they painted the car pink with
these butcher style cut marks which is a
little bit traumatic if you think about
it and then they labeled them shoulder
loin and chop and thus our pink pig was
born now the car was super fast it did
have a crash but ended up sixth overall
and now it lives on as a piece of
legendary Porsche history and an
Xbox now unfortunately these custom 75th
Anniversary Porsche Xboxes aren't for
sale but you do have an opportunity to
win one if you go to Porsche Xbox
sweepstakes.com this is where we shine
because we can crash and it doesn't
really matter we're in the Sim lab hey
Sean do you want to race
me now the Sim lab is pretty awesome if
you can't race a real car you can
actually come here and race on their
professional Sims on all sorts of really
famous racetracks after playing so much
Forza in my lifetime taking what I've
learned in a video game and then
applying it to real life racing there's
actually quite a lot of crossover except
for damaging a car in real life costs
real money and there's no respawning
okay so that was really fun and um Sean
sorry I won he's he's crying so we took
some butter to go oh no one of them has
flipped over there you go oh they're so
cold and Frozen going to save you for
breakfast
tomorrow so I'm obsessed with this wall
this is the colors of Porsche now this
isn't all of the colors so the color
that I would pick there's three this is
the brilliant red well it's a little bit
of a lighter color our pink pig I don't
think they have it exactly here but it's
called chalk and this is kind of a
similar color to it this is the dolphin
gray every time I see one of those chalk
pores out on the road my heart
melts I cannot say enough great things
about this experience I've lived in Los
Angeles for so long and this place has
been here for 7even years and I never
came to it until today so if you are in
Los Angeles if you're ever visiting
definitely come check it out make a
reservation take one of the cars out of
the track but for those of you that are
here for the Xbox you can get a chance
to win one of those at Porsche Xbox
sweepstakes.com so good luck to all of
you that enter and I look forward to
seeing who wins with that my friends I'm
going to go do a little car shopping so
many to pick
from